.
* Sanfte Trompetenklänge *
Zugegeben,
süss sind sie ja schon, die Pandas.
Doch ich verbinde das chinesische
Nationaltier auch mit etwas anderem.
Panda-Umarmer nennt man die Leute,
die China gegenüber
völlig unkritisch sind.
Das war ich nie.
Im Gegenteil,
als Journalist habe ich immer
einen sehr kritischen Blick
auf das Riesenreich.
Ich bin
in der Panda-Hauptstadt Chengdu.
Von hier aus starte ich eine Reise,
auf der ich für einmal
nur das Schöne suche.
Eine Reise,
die ich seit 15 Jahren machen will.
Mein Name ist Pascal Nufer.
Fünf Jahre lang berichtete ich
als Korrespondent aus China.
Es war eine spannende,
aber auch zermürbende Zeit,
geprägt von einem ständigen
Katz- und Mausspiel mit den Behörden.
Jetzt will ich dem Land
eine zweite Chance geben.
Ich möchte die Menschen erleben
und nicht den mächtigen Staat.
Ich will mich mit China versöhnen.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Für die Reise, die ich vorhabe,
braucht man Fahrer,
die ihr Handwerk verstehen.
Pangolin und Wulf
sind Himalaya-erfahren.
Wir sind also
an der Grenze zu Tibet.
Und wie hoch ist der höchste Punkt,
den wir überqueren?
Wie hoch ist der höchste Punkt?
Wir fahren bis auf rund 4'800 m ü.M.
Und gibt es da keine Probleme
wegen der Höhenkrankheit und so?
Wenn man keine Kreislaufprobleme
hat, sollte es gehen.
Hier habe ich Sauerstoff.
- Ah, Sauerstoff.
Ich glaube,
Angst haben muss man nicht.
Wir können im Notfall ja
auch sofort wieder runterfahren.
Das ist, glaube ich, das Wichtigste.
Wir sind dort ja
nicht total fern von der Welt hier.
Diese Reise ist ein Herzensprojekt.
Als Journalist
darf ich leider nicht nach Tibet.
Doch über sieben Himalaya-Pässe
will ich so nahe wie möglich
an die Grenze -
bis ins tibetisch geprägte
Shangri-La.
Von dort aus geht es schliesslich
in die Hippiestadt Dali.
Bevor es richtig losgehen kann ―
ein Pflichttermin.
Wir sind
in einem traditionellen Teehaus.
Nicht, weil wir das unbedingt wollen,
sondern aus taktischen Gründen.
Man darf in China nämlich
nicht einfach drauflosfilmen.
Die Regierung will ganz genau wissen,
was man macht.
Am einfachsten ist es, man wählt
möglichst unverfängliche Orte,
wie eben diese pittoreske Teestube.
Drei Aufpasser
hat uns die Regierung hergeschickt.
Wir zeigen unsere Pässe
und unseren Drehplan.
Sie lassen uns gewähren
und ziehen ab - Ziel erreicht.
Vielen Dank.
- Gern geschehen.
Ein wunderschöner Ort.
Wir hoffen,
ab jetzt ungestört und ohne Aufpasser
mit den Menschen sprechen zu können.
Mein Team besteht aus
Roger, dem Produzenten,
den beiden Fahrern Wolf und Pangolin
sowie der Dolmetscherin Feather.
Ein bisschen Proviant für den Weg.
Worauf ich mich wahnsinnig freue,
ist die Natur.
Also ich erhoffe mir wirklich,
jetzt endlich mal schöne Berge,
blauen Himmel zu sehen.
Ich wollte immer schon einmal
den Himalaya überqueren,
hab das vor x Jahren
schon einmal versucht,
als ich das allererste Mal
in China war,
und ich möchte noch einmal
einen Versuch starten,
ob wir das jetzt schaffen,
da rüber zu kommen.
Wieso hast du es damals
nicht geschafft?
Ich weiss nicht,
woran es wirklich lag.
Ich war krank.
Wir sind damals
mit dem Bus hochgefahren
und dann war ich einfach nicht fit.
Wir hatten dann Respekt,
da rüber zu fahren.
Damals waren auch die Strassen
noch nicht ausgebaut.
Man wusste nicht recht,
wie lange es dauert usw.
Dann haben wir aufgegeben.
Raus aus dem Moloch, wo das Leben der
Menschen getaktet ist wie Maschinen,
hin zu einem anderen Lebensgefühl.
Das ist mein Ziel.
* Mysteriöse Geigenklänge *
Woah!
Tibeterfahnen.
Drei, zwei, eins, Cheese.
Käse!
Gut, aber machen wir keinen Halt
in Kangding, weil es zu heikel ist?
Ja. Wir fahren durch Kangding durch
und essen erst danach etwas.
In Kangding beginnt
das tibetische Vorland, sozusagen
und da ist auch der Weg,
wo sich die Strasse teilt,
und es irgendwann
Richtung Tibet geht.
Und da sollten wir nicht mit
der Kamera in der Stadt auftauchen.
Da sind sie unglaublich vorsichtig.
Näher als hier
darf ich an Tibet gar nicht ran.
Als Journalist darf ich gar nicht
nach Tibet rein, durfte ich nie.
Es dürfen nur Leute rein,
die ein spezielles Tibet-Visum haben.
Als Journalist kann ich das
überhaupt nicht bekommen.
Und auch ansonsten darf man
als Ausländer eigentlich immer noch
nur mit einer speziellen Genehmigung
oder Bewilligung nach Tibet fahren.
Das ist ein Opa.
* Sie sprechen tibetisch. *
Mehr und mehr Menschen
sprechen nur Tibetisch.
Unser Fahrer Wolf ist der Einzige,
der sich mit ihnen
etwas unterhalten kann.
Er hat noch einen Katheter dran.
Sie waren in Chengdu im Krankenhaus.
Über 1'000 km bis zum Krankenhaus.
Ich bin immer wieder überrascht
über die Gegensätze in China.
Auf der einen Seite
ist das Land so modern
und dann wiederum
müssen Menschen 1'000 km fahren
für eine gute
medizinische Behandlung.
Das Gebiet, durch das wir fahren,
ist bereits
von der tibetischen Kultur geprägt.
Es gehört aber
nicht zur Provinz Tibet.
Anders als hier,
ist in der Provinz Tibet
der politische Status umstritten.
Viele Tibeter wären gerne unabhängig,
doch China pocht unmissverständlich
auf Zugehörigkeit.
Es ist fast schon Abend,
als wir mitten auf der Strasse
Zeuge eines etwas
eigenartigen Schauspiels werden.
Gib sie ihnen.
Gib ihnen die ganze Dose.
- Okay.
Drei Schritte nach vorne
und dann eine ganze Körperlänge,
so geht das buddhistische Pilgern.
Wir haben Kekse für euch.
Danke.
- Gern geschehen.
Sollen wir sie für euch rausnehmen?
Ich kann sie öffnen.
Will sie jetzt essen?
Nein, sie will ...
Ah, ich verstehe.
Teilt es unter euch auf.
Man gibt ihnen
offensichtlich etwas mit.
Das läuft so, glaube ich.
Aber sie haben
gar keine richtige Tasche dabei.
Greift ungeniert zu.
Pilgern ist sehr wichtig
im tibetischen Buddhismus,
die Beweggründe dafür
sind mannigfaltig.
Meistens hoffen die Pilgerinnen
auf Glück,
eine bessere Wiedergeburt
oder auf Heilung von Leiden.
Sobald es dunkel wird,
ruhen sie sich aus.
Sie rasten dort, wo sie anhalten.
Okay.
Also sobald die Sonne aufgeht,
gehen sie los.
Und wenn die Sonne untergeht,
suchen sie sich einen Ort,
wo sie übernachten können.
* Federnde elektronische Klänge *
Wahnsinn hier.
- So schön.
Bis hierher pilgern sie?
- Genau.
Das waren einige Kilometer.
Ja, ja, ja. Wir wissen ja nicht,
woher die kommen
und - woah! - in der Kälte.
* Schwebende Oboenklänge *
Nicht weit von hier schlagen auch wir
unser Nachtlager auf.
Wir sind auf 3'600 m ü.M.
Das Zimmer ist sauber und geräumig
und kostet nur 30 Euro.
Doch trotz Heizung
steigt die Temperatur nie über 7 °C.
Da freut man sich
auf die heisse Frühstückssuppe.
Wie hast du geschlafen, Roger?
Im Halbstundentakt
bin ich jeweils erwacht.
Krass, das ist wegen der Höhe.
Eine halbe Stunde Schlaf,
dann wieder eine halbe Stunde wach.
Ich auch. Hätte nicht gedacht,
dass sich die Höhe so krass auswirkt.
Und diese Kälte!
Es ist überall kalt.
Ja, es ist jetzt -11 °C
und die Türen stehen offen.
Oh, jetzt habe ich
meine Hose verbrannt.
* Lachen *
Schau, ich habe mich hier verbrannt.
Oh ja, er hat sich auch verbrannt.
Die Stimmung ist gut,
die Menschen sind freundlich,
und trotzdem ist mir etwas mulmig,
hier zu filmen.
Also solche Situationen,
wie wir da draussen
jetzt mit dem Stativ rumstehen
und mit der grossen Kamera,
dann lockt das sofort Leute an.
Wenn jetzt irgendwelche
niederrangige Behördenmitglieder
hier durchfahren
und uns sehen würden,
würden sie sich fragen:
"Was machen die hier?"
Und dann haben die oft ein Bedürfnis
in vorauseilenden Gehorsam zu sagen:
"Oh, das sind irgendwelche Ausländer,
die führen bestimmt
etwas Böses im Schilde."
Und dann kommen sie her,
wollen sehen, was wir gemacht haben.
Dann sehen sie,
dass wir vielleicht diesen Ort hier
nicht auf der Liste eingegeben haben,
weil wir das gar nicht alles können,
weil wir ja
irgendwie reagieren müssen,
und dann haben wir
sofort ein Problem.
Dann wollen sie
unser ganzes Material anschauen,
dann müssen wir
unter Umständen löschen.
Schlimmstenfalls müssen wir die Reise
abbrechen und zurück nach Chengdu.
Das ist so,
was ich über die Jahre erlebt habe.
Das gibt ein ungutes Gefühl,
weil ich immer misstrauisch bin.
Wir dürfen etwas nicht vergessen:
Diese Region hier
ist wahnsinnig heikel.
Es gab in dieser Region
nicht weit von hier ...
Vor nicht allzu langer Zeit,
wurde da eine ganze
buddhistische Siedlung plattgemacht.
Da gab's auch kleinere Aufstände, es
gab Verbrennungen hier in der Region,
Selbstverbrennungen.
Und die Behörden
sind wahnsinnig auf Zack.
Sobald
ausländische Journalisten kommen,
denken die sofort,
die wollten deshalb dort hin,
um mit den Leuten
über dieses Thema zu sprechen.
Die kommunistische Regierung hat ein
schwieriges Verhältnis zur Religion.
Lange Zeit
war jegliche Ausübung verboten.
Heute werden
die verschiedenen Glaubensrichtungen
mal mehr und mal weniger toleriert.
Aber sicher sein
können sich die Gläubigen nie.
Auch unser Fahrer Pangolin
ist Buddhist.
Er führt mich zu einem
für ihn wichtigen heiligen Hügel.
Achtung, da ist ein Loch.
Das Wasser fliesst bereits.
Schau, das dreht die Gebetsmühlen
an. Dort kann man die Mühlen sehen.
Ah, das Wasser treibt die Mühlen an.
Ja, so betet es die ganze Zeit.
Pangolin war als Fahrer oft in Tibet.
Je näher er die Menschen kennen-
gelernt hat, desto mehr hat er sich
mit der buddhistischen Weltanschauung
auseinandergesetzt.
Heute prägt der Buddhismus
sein Leben.
Hat er ein Ziel,
das er erreichen will?
Will er z.B. pilgern?
Wie weit will er gehen?
Jede Person
hat ihre eigene Ausdrucksweise.
Deshalb können wir so etwas
wahrscheinlich nicht machen.
Wenn du hier geboren bist,
ist Pilgern völlig normal.
Für mich geht es einfach darum,
ein gutes und vorbildliches Leben
zu führen.
* Sphärische Klänge *
Solche Orte wie hier oder auch
die Tempel, das ist dann möglich,
das lässt die Regierung gewähren?
Das ist eine wirklich
sehr schwierige Gratwanderung,
die die Regierung da macht.
Sie will ja eigentlich
alles unter Kontrolle haben.
Nun ist es mit der Religion so,
dass sie sich
eben nicht kontrollieren lässt.
Und das widerspricht sich.
Und deswegen will die chinesische
Regierung jetzt z.B. bestimmen,
wer Nachfolger
des jetzigen Dalai-Lamas wird.
Und das ist ja eigentlich absurd,
dass die kommunistische Partei Chinas
jetzt bestimmen soll,
wer spirituelles Oberhaupt einer
ganzen Glaubensgemeinschaft wird.
Sie schrauben ein bisschen da,
ein bisschen dort.
Die Tibeter sind nun mal hier
und sie sind nun mal religiös.
Man kann die jetzt nicht
von einem Tag auf den anderen
irgendwie umstimmen.
Versuche gab es immer wieder.
Ähnliche Versuche
gibt's im Moment mit den Muslimen,
dass sie versuchen, diese im Denken
umzuschulen. Also das passiert schon.
Hallo.
Sein Name ist Puwa.
- Puwa.
Ist das Ihre Herde?
- Ja, unsere.
Brauchen Sie sie wegen des Fleisches
oder wegen der Milch?
Wir verkaufen alles davon:
das Fleisch, das Leder
und die Milchprodukte.
Ja, einfach alles.
Läuft es gut?
- Ja.
Ich kann mich nicht beklagen,
aber eigentlich bete ich gerade.
So, jetzt bin ich fertig.
Hat er einen Traum?
Ist er bereits glücklich?
Oder ist da etwas,
was er erreichen möchte?
* Sie sprechen tibetisch. *
Er kann mit der Frage
nicht viel anfangen.
Ich glaube,
die Frage macht für ihn keinen Sinn.
Das Konzept Traum ist zu abstrakt.
Er ist einfach zufrieden
mit seinem Leben.
* Sphärische Klänge *
Heute erreichen wir
den höchsten Punkt unserer Reise.
Beautiful!
Wow!
4'548 m ü.M.
Dem ganzen Team geht es,
abgesehen von gelegentlichen
Kopfschmerzen, ausgezeichnet.
Beautiful!
- Beautiful!
Hier wollte ich
schon vor 15 Jahren stehen.
Ich bin echt glücklich,
dass es dieses Mal geklappt hat.
In den Bergen oben
ist es besonders heilig.
Wir beten für das Glück von allen.
Du musst das Gummiband wegnehmen.
- Ja, ich weiss.
Sergio.
Was ist dein Wunsch für die Zukunft?
Für mich persönlich?
Ich möchte, dass ich diese Zeit
mein Leben lang
in schöner Erinnerung behalten kann,
dass ich mit schönen Erinnerungen
nach Hause gehen kann,
die auch für meine Familie
und für meine Kinder
als schöne Erinnerungen bleiben.
Dass auch sie, wenn sie
einmal erwachsen sein werden,
zurückdenken
an eine unglaubliche Zeit,
die wir hier in China
verbringen durften.
Das ist ein grosser Wunsch von mir.
(Alle) One, two, three.
* Mysteriöse Oboenklänge *
Wir erreichen ein Gebiet, das bekannt
ist für seine schönen Menschen.
Hier irgendwo
soll es auch ein Dorf geben,
in dem
die schönsten Männer Chinas leben.
Wir haben Reporterglück und treffen
an der Strasse auf zwei Yak-Hirten.
Sie kommen aus dem Dorf,
wo die schönsten Männer herkommen?
Sie sind also aus Kanba?
- Ja, genau.
Aha, deshalb verhüllen sie sich.
Warum ist das so?
Was ist die Geschichte dahinter?
Warum sind denn
die Männer bei euch so hübsch?
Wir sind grösser als die Chinesen.
Die Haare und der Bart
sind auch schöner.
Ausserdem wachsen wir
einfach hübscher heran.
Das würden wir jetzt
aber gerne sehen.
Achtung, Achtung.
Oh, ja.
Hübsch, sehr hübsch.
Ich habe ihm die Haare geschnitten.
Sehr gut!
Acht Monate im Jahr
wohnen die beiden Cousins hier.
Jetzt im Winter gehen sie abends
wieder ins Dorf zurück.
Ni hao. Ni hao. Ni hao.
Bitte, nimm Platz.
- Xie xie, xie xie. Ni hao.
Bitte, nehmt Platz.
Wie heisst du?
Sag ihm, wie du heisst.
Dinsi-Unsi.
- Dinsi-Unsi.- Genau.
Danke.
Das erste Mal im Leben bekomme ich
getrocknetes Yak-Fleisch gereicht.
Es ist gefroren.
Das ist was Gutes.
Es ist nicht gesalzen.
Etwas nachsalzen
und es schmeckt ganz gut.
Sie hätten Salz, aber sie
mögen den Geschmack einfach nicht.
Auch er scheint,
hier ein modernes Leben zu führen.
Ist es ein gutes Leben?
Oder träumt er von etwas anderem?
Ich möchte in die Stadt ziehen.
Viele junge Leute wollen nichts mehr
mit Landwirtschaft zu tun haben.
Jahr für Jahr
passe ich auf die Herde auf.
Ich werde die Yaks verkaufen,
dann hält mich hier nichts mehr.
Was willst du denn tun,
wenn du nicht mehr Hirte sein willst?
Ich weiss noch nicht.
Was ich finden werde.
Auch hier oben zieht es
die jungen Menschen in die Stadt.
Dies, obwohl hier das sagenumwobene
Shangri-La-Gebiet liegen soll,
dieser Himmel auf Erden,
in dem die Bewohner unsterblich sind,
wie es James Hilton in seinem Roman
"Lost Horizon" beschrieben hat.
In Shangri-La
gibt es Berge und Flüsse,
es gibt Weideland und Schneeberge.
Alles ist üppig.
Es ist ein Ort, wo Götter wohnen.
Hier gibt es alles.
* Mysteriöses Dröhnen *
Die Landschaft, durch die wir fahren,
bewegt etwas in mir.
Ich verstehe immer besser,
warum über dieses Gebiet
Romane geschrieben werden.
Hier auf dem Dach der Welt
ist man dem Himmel
tatsächlich ein bisschen näher.
* Schwebende Trompetenklänge *
Unser nächstes Ziel
ist die Stadt Shangri-La.
Erst seit 2001 heisst der Ort so -
aus Marketinggründen.
Riesig.
Ja, es sieht anders aus,
als ich das in Erinnerung habe.
Ich kann mich nicht erinnern,
dass das so gross war, aber ...
Ja, mal schauen.
Ich erinnere mich
an den Altstadtteil.
Wir sind jetzt
irgendwo ausserhalb noch.
Da war irgendwo
dieser Tempel oberhalb.
Vor 15 Jahren machte ich die Reise
von der anderen Seite her
und musste hier aufgeben.
Damals gab es
kaum asphaltierte Strassen.
Die Stadt hat sich stark verändert.
Immerhin - den grossen Tempel
auf dem Hügel gibt's noch.
Man spürt schon, dass wir auch
hier oben noch auf 3'300 m ü.M. sind.
Lasst uns gehen.
Ich bin so erschöpft.
Wir haben die Reise
bislang ohne Doping geschafft.
Oben erwartet mich
eine gigantische Gebetsmühle.
Mir kommt das Sprichwort
"Viel hilft viel" in den Sinn.
Ich werde also
den Eindruck nicht ganz los,
dass das einfach
das Grösste sein muss.
Von hier
hat man einen guten Überblick
über die Altstadt von Shangri-La.
Ich weiss noch,
dass mich der Ort beim ersten Besuch
ziemlich beeindruck hat.
Ich fühlte mich wohl.
Ich bin gespannt, was von
diesem Geist noch übriggeblieben ist.
Dhakbar, der Besitzer meines Hotels,
hat die Stadtentwicklung
der letzten Jahre hautnah miterlebt.
Er ist in der tibetischen Kultur
tief verwurzelt.
Er nimmt mich mit
auf eine kurze Stadtführung.
Das in der Mitte
ist der Chegemone Tempel
und auf der linken Seite
ist eine Gebetsmühle.
Das ist eine grosse Gebetsmühle.
Ja, es heisst,
sie soll die weltgrösste sein.
Die Leute gehen
an bestimmten Tagen in die Altstadt.
Sie beten und pilgern.
Auch beten sie für die ganze
Altstadt, für Gesundheit und Glück.
Ist der Buddhismus für die Leute, die
hier leben, immer noch sehr wichtig?
Ja, sehr wichtig.
Es leben sieben Minderheiten
in dieser kleinen Ortschaft:
die Tibeter, die Naxi, die Yi,
die Pumi und weitere Minderheiten
wie die Han, sieben im Ganzen.
Auf kleinstem Raum leben alle
sehr harmonisch miteinander.
Seit der Umbenennung in Shangri-La
flanieren im Sommer Hunderttausende
durch die Altstadtgassen.
Jetzt im Winter ist es schön ruhig.
Überall buddhistische Insignien
und Chinaflaggen,
sehr viele Chinaflaggen.
Da sind ja viele Fahnen.
- Ja, genau.
Aber es ist verboten, eine
tibetische Flagge zu haben, nicht?
Wir haben keine tibetische Flaggen,
aber buddhistische Fahnen.
Über Politik mag Dhakbar
nicht so wirklich sprechen.
Lieber zeigt er mir einen Ort,
der ihm besonders am Herzen liegt.
Bevor du kamst, hatte ich die Türe
bereits aufgeschlossen.
Der Wind hat sie
wohl wieder zugedrückt.
Möglicherweise hilft die Bank.
Vielleicht hilft das ja.
* Türgong *
* Chinesische Lautsprecherstimme *
Das ist das Thangka Center,
das Zentrum für Kulturbewahrung
von Shangri-La.
Hier lernen Tibeter Malerei.
Das ist ein Thangka-Bild.
Es ist eine Karte von ganz Tibet.
Das ist Zentraltibet,
Osttibet und Westtibet.
Shangri-La ist genau hier.
Das Bild zeigt einen Dämon.
Ganz Tibet ist sehr rau.
Das Leben ist hart.
Aber all das Spirituelle
macht es friedlich.
Das ist nun doch sehr erstaunlich:
Tibet ist hier einfach Tibet,
egal welcher Teil - ohne Grenze.
Müssen die Malerei-Studenten
dafür bezahlen?
Nein, es ist gratis.
Wir unterstützen die Einheimischen.
Vier Jahre Studium,
das Essen und die Unterkünfte,
alles ist kostenlos.
Ah.
- Ja.
Okay. Das ist also wirklich ...
Dienst an der Gemeinschaft, jawohl.
Irgendwie überrascht es mich,
wie viel tibetische Kultur
hier sichtbar ist.
Oder ist das alles nur eine Show,
um von der Unterdrückung andernorts
abzulenken?
Schwer zu sagen.
Mich berührt jedenfalls
das friedliche Miteinander.
Natürlich weiss ich auch,
dass die Regierung die Zügel
jederzeit gnadenlos anziehen kann.
Am Abend folge ich der Musik
und bekomme gleich
eine weitere Kostprobe.
* Elektronische Tanzmusik *
* Tibetischer Männergesang *
Das hat sich nicht verändert.
Das war schon das letzte Mal so,
vor 15 Jahren,
als ich zum ersten Mal hier war.
Damals waren wir so fasziniert,
dass wir gleich mitgetanzt haben.
* Der Rhythmus der elektronischen
Tanzmusik wird schneller. *
Es ist zu anstrengend
auf dieser Höhe, boah.
Ich merke die Höhe, boah.
Was ist das für ein Tanz?
Tibeter nennen das Chango.
In ganz Tibet tanzt man den Chango.
Also am Abend kommen die Leute
zusammen und tanzen?
Nicht nur am Abend,
morgens, mittags, am Nachmittag.
Immer wird getanzt.
* Lebhafte elektronische Tanzmusik
mit tibetischem Frauengesang *
* Die elektronische Tanzmusik
klingt aus. *
* Husten *
Auch dieses Mal habe ich mich
sehr wohl gefühlt hier oben.
Langsam aber verlassen wir
die tibetische Kultur
und fahren weiter
in die Hippiestadt Dali.
Wir fahren talwärts
und geniessen einen letzten Blick
auf die majestätischen Berge.
* Schwebende Trompetenklänge *
Entlang der 250 km langen Strecke:
Baustelle an Baustelle.
Ein neuer Hochgeschwindigkeitszug
und eine Autobahn
sollen den Tourismus in der Region
weiter vorantreiben.
In Dali, so sagt man mir,
habe sich diese Entwicklung
schon längst vollzogen.
Als ich damals
als Rucksacktourist hier war,
spürte man davon noch wenig.
* Schwebende Trompetenklänge *
* Pulsierende Bässe
elektronischer Tanzmusik *
Die berüchtigten
chinesischen Reisegruppen,
so wie wir sie kennen,
gibt's hier auch.
Doch auch viele Individualtouristen -
Ausdruck der immer
grösser werdenden Mittelschicht.
Von der einstigen Hippiestadt
ist im Zentrum nichts mehr zu spüren.
* Wehmütige Flötenklänge *
Doch es soll sie noch geben,
die alternative Szene.
* Lebhafte Jazztrompetenklänge *
Ein Tipp meiner Übersetzerin
brachte mich in diese Bar.
Und tatsächlich lerne ich schnell
Kreative und Aussteiger
aus aller Welt kennen.
Denkst du,
Dali ist einzigartig in China?
Definitiv. Sehr, sehr einzigartig.
Denn auch jetzt kommen noch immer
Menschen aus den
verschiedensten Schichten hierher.
Man nennt es baolong.
Bye-bye.
Baolong bedeutet akzeptieren -
ganz unterschiedliche Menschen
zu akzeptieren.
Denn es ist egal,
woher man kommt, ob reich oder arm.
Man kann hier überleben,
wenn man will.
Das gibt es
in den grossen Städten nicht.
Man muss dort Regeln befolgen, die
die Gesellschaft aufgestellt hat.
Man kauft sich ein Haus,
wird schwanger, bekommt ein Baby
und hat einen anständigen Job,
dann ein gutes Auto
oder tauscht es
gegen ein anderes Haus ein. Ja.
Es ist schon spät, als ich mit
Phillip und Ojang ins Gespräch komme.
Phillip ist
ein spiritueller Weltenbummler,
der seine Heimat England
vor acht Jahren verlassen hat.
Als ich zum ersten Malhierher kam,
dachte ich nur:
"Da sind ja überall Hippies."
Später merkte ich,
dass es hier ganz cool ist.
Zumindest lebt hier jeder
seine Individualität,
woanders ist das schwer zu finden.
Dann traf ich irgendwann Ojang
und wurde hier sesshaft.
Hello.
Hier fand ich viele Freunde
und beschloss, einfach zu bleiben.
Nicht weil ich anderen Orten
gegenüber abgeneigt wäre,
sondern wegen der
besonderen Stimmung hier.
Sicher gefällt es mir hier.
Dali macht mich sehr gesund.
Hier gibt es echtes Essen.
Biologisches Essen zu niedrigen
Preisen, die ich mir leisten kann.
Am nächsten Morgen
bei Phillip und Ojang zu Hause.
Sie leben in einem Dorf
ausserhalb der Stadt.
Phillip studierte drei Jahre
bei Mönchen im Shaolin-Kloster.
Man erzählt sich,
dass die alten Kung-Fu-Meister
ein unglaublich
scharfes Schwert nahmen,
* Sirren des Schwerts *
um damit eine Gurke zu schneiden,
als wäre sie weich wie Butter.
Sie konnten das Qi
in ihrem Bauch aufbauen
bis zu einem Punkt,
in der sie die Gurke schnitten,
ohne ihrer eigene Haut zu schaden.
* Sirren des Schwerts, Schrei *
Hat es weh getan?
- Ein bisschen.
Ein schneller Gurkensalat.
Ojang und Phillip
wohnen seit einem Jahr hier.
Oft sind Freunde zu Besuch.
Alles Menschen,
die in Dali ein alternatives
Lebensgefühl gefunden haben.
Apropos Tattoos.
Mein ganzer Körper
ist mit Tattoos bedeckt.
Das sind heilige
mathematische Formeln.
Bis hin zum Oberkörper alles Symbole
von verschiedenen Religionen,
Zeichen, luzide Träume und alles,
was ich in meinem Leben gelernt habe
und nie vergessen möchte.
Und die in deinem Gesicht?
Das hier teilt meinen Körper
in zwei Hälften.
Auf der linken Seite meines Körpers
habe ich nur ein einziges Tattoo
und das befindet sich am Gesäss:
ein lachendes Gesicht.
Es soll mich daran erinnern,
dass man sich auf der eine Seite
tief über Dinge Gedanken machen kann
und alles sammeln,
was einem wichtig erscheint.
Aber auf der anderen Seite
ist das einzig Wichtige,
doch einfach glücklich zu sein.
Das ist eine Klangschale.
Man spielt das Instrument, indem man
den Klöppel am Rand entlangführt,
bis ein Ton erklingt.
Es ist ein sehr tiefer Ton.
Ursprünglich kam die Klangschale
aus Tibet.
Okay.
Du musst es so weiterführen,
bis ein Ton erklingt.
Dabei musst du schauen,
dass du gleichmässige
und langsame Bewegungen machst.
Geht's mit der kleineren einfacher?
Nein, wenn du sie auf den Boden
legst. Versuch den hier.
* Schwebender Klang *
Vom Meister einmal in Schwung
gebracht, schaffe auch ich einen Ton.
Du brauchst ein wenig Kraft,
aber nicht allzu viel.
Okay.
- Ja, ja, ja. Schön.
* Schwebender Klang *
* Tibetischer Kehlkopfgesang *
Kommt ihr hier durch?
Eine Nachbarin kommt vorbei
und lädt mich spontan
zu einer besonderen Art
der Körpermeditation ein.
Für die alten Gemäuer hier
interessieren sich wenige.
Deshalb können Philip
und seine Freunde hier günstig leben.
Hallo. Willkommen.
Ich bin Pascal.
- Ich bin Yi.
Schön, dich kennenzulernen.
Das ist Sergio, unser Kameramann.
- Schön, dich kennenzulernen.
Ihr müsst mir das erklären.
Wir halten uns an den Händen,
die linke nach oben,
die rechte nach unten.
Fühle, wie das Einatmen
das Innere deiner Haut berührt.
Jedes Ausatmen ist eine Einladung.
Nimm diese Einladung an.
Atemübungen kenne ich vom Yoga,
doch was jetzt folgt,
war mir bislang unbekannt.
Spüre deinen Körper.
Fühle dich wohl darin.
* Schwebende Trompetenklänge *
Und langsam zum Stillstand.
Die linke Hand empfängt,
die rechte Hand gibt.
Danke, dass ihr mir gezeigt habt,
dass es auch in China Leute gibt,
die anders leben.
Natürlich war es viel zu kurz.
Du wirkst ja sehr enttäuscht.
- Nein.
Das war viel zu kurz.
Ich könnte noch länger tanzen.
Lass mich erklären.
Also das Hauptthema ...
Ich mache vier Dokumentarfilme
und sie alle drehen sich
hauptsächlich um Versöhnung,
um wieder Frieden
mit China zu finden.
Jetzt habe ich wirklich Gänsehaut.
Das berührt mich.
Nein, wirklich. Ich möchte ...
Ich denke,
es ist auch für uns eine Reise,
um uns mit China zu versöhnen.
Denn mit diesem gesellschaftlichen
Druck und all den dunklen Seiten -
die verschmutzte Umwelt
und solche Sachen.
Doch hier sind unsere Wurzeln.
Und es gibt ja trotz allem
viele schöne Dinge:
die Natur, die traditionelle Kultur,
die Spiritualität, einfach alles.
Deshalb sind auch wir
auf einer Reise der Versöhnung.
Endlich habe ich
ein bisschen Frieden gefunden.
Komm bald zurück.
Ja, hoffentlich.
Es ist ein ganz,
ganz anderes China als das,
was ich in meiner fünfjährigen Arbeit
hier als Journalist erlebt habe,
wo ich eben auch immer gezwungen war,
auf das Negative zu schauen
und auch kaum Zeit hatte.
Man muss sich ja auch
darauf einlassen.
Wir haben jetzt
doch ein paar Tage gebraucht,
bis wir hierhergekommen sind
und es gefunden haben.
Man muss sich öffnen und es zulassen.
Und man muss vielleicht wirklich
die Vorurteile einfach mal weglegen.
Da spielt es auch keine Rolle mehr,
wer jetzt Chinese ist,
wer Engländer oder wer Schweizer ist.
Man kann ja einfach Mensch sein.
Und das ist das, was oft ...
Das Menschsein kommt in China
manchmal zu kurz.
Man denkt immer,
es seien alle gleichgeschaltet,
es sei ein Apparat
einer Milliarde Ameisen,
aber es ist natürlich nicht so.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Roger Schmid - 2020